scp-682 versus a fighter jet who would  win well that depends on your definition  of when in terms of short-term  immobilization required for getting 682  recontained a fighter jet would likely  be an asset to any MTF hoping to get 682  back under control given its high speed  and weapons capable of at least  effectively stalling the monster however  if we're talking to the death then we'll  have to consider that missiles and  conventional arms Fire have no lasting  effect against 682 given enough time it  would either adapt to either fly or  fling projectiles capable of taking the  jet down or both imagine a flying  missile launching 682 wow that's  absolutely terrifying